i don't know how many of you guys are
familiar with the term posers i don't
hear it that much
anymore um where did we come up with
posers
i think it was like a thing from
skateboard days when i was a kid when
you know my buddy would have like the
tony hawk and i had the steve caballero
and we were on the half pipe and there
was always that one kid
that wouldn't ride the pipe he would
just kind of stand there posing with his
port
and his pads um sometimes his mom would
come around and take pictures with him
with a little snap camera
or you roll it sort of thing but he had
all the gear you know the clothing
and he would just kind of pose all right
not a big deal he was scared maybe who
knows
but these guys uh you know they show up
a few other times in life now
the weird thing is is after about the
high school years 20 or so
i didn't really come across a lot of
posers frauds clout chasers and fakers
um i'm trying to think of the major
epoch so if i were to break it down
major epochs in life for me after
20 would have been the credit collection
years which was about 20 to 30.
um 30 on i was deeply involved in
entrepreneurs organization building my
business uh through the hyper growth
years and everything that we did
so it'd be one two three i would say
about three and then the fourth one
would be what i'm doing with
entrepreneurs and cars
right yeah surfing also refers to posers
i think surfering
the surfing uh was the origin of it all
especially when it kind of tied into
skating because when
surfers weren't surfing they were
skating a lot of times so there's there
was always posers that were kind of
out and about and they purport to be
something that they're not
and i think you got to be really careful
with um
who you surround yourself with i mean
i've always said this guys you got to be
super careful with who you surround
yourself with
steve made a funny comment up here about
the barney uh
guys um on the you know on the ski
slopes there'd always be these guys that
wouldn't ski but they had the full
outfit on the very expensive outfit and
the varney sunglasses and all that [ __ ]
but they couldn't ski for crap you would
never see them anyway
but um yeah that's what we're talking
about now i haven't seen these
people in my 20s and my 30s it's only
when i started doing this youtube
channel stuff
and then it started to grow and it got
bigger and i was talking about
uh you know basically making my wounds
my work which is really
how this whole thing pivoted and then
for some reason i kind of tripped into
this space i wasn't looking for it i
wasn't
i wasn't trying to solve any kind of
like most guys that find uh
places on youtube or even this thing
they call the mano swamp
i'm gonna call it the manoswam because
that's really what it is it's a swamp
um they go you know they end up there
because they're looking to solve their
reproductive issues more specifically
because they're trying to get dug girls
you know um it's kind of an ongoing
crack that aaron cleary and i
uh have used i even titled one of the
chapters in my book how to get the girls
to kind of ride off on that a little bit
more to build on it
if you're unfamiliar with the origin of
it but
never happened in my 20s you know i was
in the credit collection world for
almost 10 11 years i think and
did really well you know went up through
the ranks
awful quickly we used to have this uh
avatar that that we used to use with um
guys that were we used to call them
telephone tough guys
so if you're not familiar in the credit
collection worlds um
people aren't that keen on getting you
know phone calls about paying their
bills
and in some cases they would be
threatening you know come down there and
rip off your head and crap down your
throat and all this sort of stuff
and these telephone tough guys would run
their mouths on the phone
of course they're in debt you know so
they're not masters of uh finances to
begin with but
they would run their mouths on the phone
and every single time they would show up
politely quietly hand over the the money
the draft
posted a checks whatever it is that they
were dropping off and walk away
there's no conflict no fight it was all
hot air it was all talk
posers right okay well that's one time
that i've seen it i didn't see it
once my entire time i was
yeah that's that's a good point uh conch
kong says telephone tough guy is a
precursor to keyboard warrior
same sort of thing um i remember when
forums started to become popular
uh there was one in in the mid 2000s
uh that i was using in the credit
collection world and there was always
these keyboard warriors
and you know we used to joke and say
that all you need
is an internet connection and a computer
and you too can be an expert
on the topic too faceless no idea who
they are
made up avatar names have no idea about
their origin
what's behind it and it's very difficult
to assess them
sometimes you know a lot of them were
you know huge posers too
uh what do you got there omni thanks for
okay so channel membership um omni says
hey mr cooper i paid the live chat for
you because i truly want you to know
that you're appreciated both your words
and experience i'm listening and taking
notes good man thanks appreciate it
listen i get a lot of love from you guys
emails dms i you know appreciate the
support whatever super chats all that
kind of stuff it's awesome thank you
very much
um i know the impact is there there's
there's there's no question in my mind
um don't don't worry about that um
so moving on to the 30s
when i switched over to entrepreneurship
so i took a package and i went home i
talked a little bit about it in my book
as well but i took a package went home
at about 30.
and what do i do i set up my own
business kind of tied in to
what i had learned and where i saw an
opportunity it was like that whole like
luck preparation opportunity all kind of
collides and meets in one spot
and something big came out of it okay so
now i've gone from
you know 100 120 000 year employee
to writing my own paycheck within
i'm going to say within the first year
things were
great within five years we were in hyper
growth
right within about the sixth year i
think we were doing like
three hundred thousand dollars a month
so by that point
we we meeting like the business itself
and me had qualified to
enter into entrepreneurs org and if you
don't know what that is it's
a global organization that helps
facilitate the growth of
entrepreneurs personally and in their
business and one of the
really really nice parts of that is you
get to
get involved into these groups called
forums where you meet privately with
usually
seven to ten uh guys sometimes there's a
couple of gals in the forum but it's
mostly men
and um you know you help potentially
level up there's retreats there's global
events there's
national events uh really just like top
shelf guys you know
i always tell you guys if you're the
smartest guy in the room you're in the
wrong room get out of the room move into
a better room right so if you find
yourself sitting around you're like
there's a lot of dumb people in here and
you know they're like anchors sort of
thing
you want to get out of that room and
move and put yourself in a better place
if you're sitting around posers you're
definitely in the wrong room so
eo becomes a thing for me um i start
doing the eoa stuff
which is basically mentoring uh startup
entrepreneurs which were
somewhere between 250 000 a year plus uh
up to about a million a year in sales
and then what we try to do is we get
them up over a million dollars to
graduate them to eo which is over a
million dollars in annual sales
so i'm around all these people and a
weird thing happened that i
that i kind of reflected back on just
now in the last week when i was kind of
prepping for this
uh because every week i got to come up
with a topic right it's it's kind of the
thing with before the train wreck i'm
like okay so what sort of stories can we
talk about what
lessons can we share with with guys and
gals out there that don't want to make
mistakes in their
life right so there's not a single
person that spend
any of their time in that area like the
telephone tough guys were gone they were
a thing of the past
after that there was not a single person
around me that
was disparaging was a poser was a clout
chaser
was a fraud not one for years
these were guys that were i mean
some of the guys in my form personally
uh
a guy that got wiped out in a hurricane
because he was working an accounting
firm in uh the cayman islands
said [ __ ] it and then he started to
summit the seven peaks on all seven
continents
so this is a guy that walked up seven
mountains the tallest peaks in the world
comes back and then sets up a highly
successful chain
of daycare centers uh
another guy that built one i think it
was the second or
third probably the second biggest toy
company in the world
um sorry north america um because there
was a lot of asian suppliers that
retired in that too so i forgot about
that
but uh large non-profit organizations
like the top three in in canada like
like these are all highly successful
people
and they spent none of their time none
of their time whatsoever
being posers disparaging others trying
to bring other people down
making up stuff about them they were on
their purpose right like they were
chasing excellence
they were doing something of importance
and significance
you